hi Conan O'Brien here I'm standing
alongside
my companion and professional irritant
Jordan shlansky hey Jordan hi good to
see you thank you likewise yeah yeah
warmth radiates off you I wanted to
bring something up which is uh
I wound up
the uh the Late Night show oh yes I know
now
that meant some people uh took other
kinds of jobs some people maybe did some
things that they're ashamed of but we
all do what we have to do in trying
times to get by is that correct yes it's
true that you have been paying me a
reduced salary and I've been depleting
my life savings while you have been
mentally preparing to start thinking
about a new show over one year after the
old show ended that's completely true I
owe you a living is that what you're
saying I owe you a living what I'm
saying you can't what am I you're just
some piece of clay and I need to breathe
on you so you can come to life what I'm
saying is if I've contributed in some
small way to some Financial games that
you may have achieved in the past year
uh if you feel that last year you got
paid to do nothing you got paid for
years to do nothing no one knows what
you do no one has any clue what you do
you always have the same answer well I
have various and there are various and I
have various tasks okay is this because
you're unemployable outside of my
outside of my world no one else wants to
employ are you claiming you've publicly
sullied my reputations no right where
I'm unemployable yeah owe me nothing in
return
I was just asking you're saying I accept
you're saying that I need to do a show
in order
to employ you to do not have you ever
publicly ridiculed my work ethic to the
point where I may be unattractive to
another employee have you tried have you
tried it did you ever publicly ridiculed
any part of me or my work ethic I did
that rid of you were an employer and you
were prospectively thinking about hiring
and you opened the internet and saw what
you saw would you hire me you've tried
to get work and you couldn't get work I
would like you to start thinking about a
show okay I know you have your projects
I know you have your celebrity friends
you have your dinners with Timothy
Oliphant you don't need to be hungry
anymore because you've achieved a
certain situation but do you look like
the kind of guy that wants to Decay
mentally comedically do you think you
just come back five years later and
people will care whether you're like
some Roman Emperor Kaiser which is the
Original Latin pronunciation by the way
not the ecclesiastical which would be
Cesar but nevertheless you think people
will just come as you sit there on your
throne I'm ready to entertain you now
okay okay okay I want you to calm down
you have become unhinged okay that was
insane okay because it's come to my my
attention it came to my attention a
while ago that you were making money off
of Cameo okay is that true that's true
yeah for our viewers like my parents who
won't understand what is cameo Cameo is
a website where famous people can record
greetings for people either as a gift to
somebody else to celebrate an occasion
or even just as a gift to themselves
let's see what it says here
Jordan schlansky associate producer it
says here book now for
159.99 well if you book it through the
website you'll get a 9.99 discount it'll
be 150 even you look what's happened to
you this is this is stating the facts I
mean it's directly responding to your
mode of questioning all right let's look
at one of your cameos I want to see
these I'm Jordan schlansky and this
message is for Javier I was contacted by
Marin who let me know that you were
celebrating a birthday July 18th I'm
here to wish you feliz cumpleanos and to
let you know that I noticed your zodiac
sign is Cancer who are known
specifically to take great pleasure in
the Comforts of home I'm gonna stop you
there
were you held hostage when you did this
what are you doing what is this you
don't even sound like yourself you've
been brainwashed by these monsters I'm
being held hostage in a factory how are
you listed in here are you oh I'm listed
under comedy
people find me humorous
you're a comedian by the way I'm a
surgeon I don't know if you're aware of
that I work on the eyes and the Brain 28
years on TV yeah Carson got out after
30. you'd see anyone outside his gate
yelling at him
laughs
a couple of months after he retired
after 30 years of entertaining America
do you think there was someone outside
his office going yeah
I mean you called freaking Johnny get
off your ass
right let me get this straight
people contact you that's correct and
they ask for a certain kind of greeting
yeah
um okay I'd like to know how that works
so okay let's just say
that I've called and my son
Jacob is having a bar mitzvah okay have
at it well I do some research before I
record I can't just act out like a
monkey I hear a beck and call because
you decided you want me to fall into
something that normally takes a lot of
preparations for me I take this very
seriously I'll give you 200 cash
Jacob I have worked with your father for
many years he was a successful comic
personality for 28 years and now he
feels as if he can take some time he's
announced there will be a new show and
one would expect maybe it'll be two
months maybe it'll be three and then
some people that work for him like
myself are standing by just waiting sure
there have been physical consequences my
life has fallen apart as had the lives
of many others explain why you can't get
another job but it's also possible that
my employer has a publicly explain why
you can't get another job public
publicly
um claim that I'm unemployable like my
work ethic is a subpar I don't do
anything I come into work late okay and
this is not a cameo for this kid happy
Bar Mitzvah Jacob this guy's ranting
about the collapse of his life I think
when he even mentioned me it brings up
rage issues for you so what I want to do
is pretend this person is not in any way
related to me okay okay so let's say my
name is Hans meternik okay
um and I'm going in tomorrow to have my
right leg amputated did okay Hans you're
getting your right leg amputated but
judging by your German name you're
probably in a country that has public
health care that's free which is a good
thing because if you were in a country
like the United States where the proper
Health Care could cost money and you
were financially challenged much like
myself in this current time due to my
current employer who pays me a reduced
salary uh you might have a problem
getting that right leg amputated in the
optimal manner make sure you have the
proper funding to get the surgery and to
get the proper funding make sure you're
employable don't ever do anything
publicly that might lessen the chances
of successful employment in the future
it's possible you may have an employer
that asked you to parade around the
streets of a foreign city nude which
could be detrimental to a foreign
employer like someone like Disney that
has virtues okay okay these are terrible
Cameo videos awful I haven't had any
complaints they're well
you haven't had any complaints for a
reason no one wants to admit they paid
money to this madman no one wants to
talk about that public they're ashamed
they're filled with the shame one has
one one has wasted their money thrown it
down the toilet No One's Gonna Come
forward and say hey I I know I gave you
200 and you're not you're nobody you
yelled at me on Cameo for 20 minutes
about your financial problems because
your boss only pays you half of what he
used to pay you to do nothing and
you refuse to get out of work Jordan
listen yes you and I are friends okay
and I promise you that you and I will
work together again yeah in several
years when I'm ready to come back
it's going to be 2044 when I make my
triumphant return and boy is America
going to [ __ ] itself when I announced
that I'm coming back
because kids won't forget me they never
will people in television especially
comedians they never go out of style and
they're never forgotten ever so you wait
and see 30 years from now when I am over
100 years old I'm going to make my
triumphant return with hard-edged comedy
that's going to blow the socks off
American kids everywhere let's shake on
it
Jordan God bless you you're a good man